this is penny from Nashville Tennessee
she's using a phone app to speak cat yes
this is Penny's voice translated into
meow and oh look flam a cat just loves
it or maybe not but I'd love to know
what she actually said to the cat so
would we they can't human cat translator
can this app really talk to it tabby
despite having domesticated cats for so
long we actually know very little about
what their different sounds me even
though there's this cat communication
app it's really more for entertainment
value well it doesn't seem like much fun
for the cat why is this feline acting so
ferociously what it's hearing is the
sound of a different cat a catheter
doesn't know and can't see right there
in the middle of its territory flam
lashes out at poor penny and this is
something called redirected aggression
it's actually quite common in cats and
basically flam is feeling threatened and
he's feeling like he needs to react and
Penny is the closest one round
I can talk cat you just go mio mio mio
well-done sod no no no